goes back to your saying one of the best
ways to make it is to have a big
personality yeah be outgoing you can't
be lame man yeah or if you don't know
how to interview go check out our water
app and go how do I try any of you
better make good answers I can I tell
you what do you like about school lunch
don't ever answer a question like that
what you answer a question like there's
so the listener can know what question
you answer what I like about lunch first
of all is lunch
I like burritos I hate standing in line
you know I hate where I lose my my meal
ticket mm-hmm details bro details
I hate when you would ask a personal
question and going yeah [ __ ] that dude I
want to punch him in the [ __ ] face
dude if I don't get a long answer from
you you better get the [ __ ] at the
podcast yeah I hate when I had to do all
the talking because people are lame
they're [ __ ] shy I hate it bro
I hate whenever I gotta do a podcast
from our publicist and we have a young
person who doesn't know how to do any
views so you have a new album come out
yeah okay you fat ass where is he coming
on it and another thing also if you're
gonna be a guest on a podcast as soon as
you get off the podcast go tell people
you're on that podcast mmm if you're
begging to be on a podcast one thing I
hate the most is you beg to be on my
podcast and then when I posted you're
gonna be on my podcast with a photo and
you don't need to eat it
I got did a podcast with this guy right
here and I kept going after that comment
but we're gonna put the [ __ ] podcast
up and he never even put in his [ __ ]
page what's wrong Felipe Esparza you're
nobody I know you are that's why yeah no
one I keep asking them we're gonna put
the podcaster we're gonna bro I took
time to do your podcast you never put it
up I want to kill him bro I wasting my
time on your lame podcast you didn't put
it up [ __ ] that [ __ ] bro well
we're putting this on Willie Barcena
kicked his ass I was happy
a word but the guy started off with he's
crazy now bro now he's he's lazy bro I
assumed it was back they found out that
that comedian was doing his joke and he
was on his way to Vegas from Corpus he
made a u-turn and went to El Paso and
went to a restaurant and try to kick his
ass
what'd you get bro for not posting that
podcast and how you can have a podcast
and not posted on your page and put your
lame comedy there I don't know this was
going up there I promise I don't want to
get killed what was the real quick what
was the fluffy situation what were you
guys arguing about was it business what
business broker he was just he just say
um are the opener were gaining $200 for
that week all right just say for example
okay we're not getting that much okay
way more than that okay I was like wait
what but this fool are laying bro okay
and he half of his act is about about me
right so he imitating me too right and
doing my newest sons and kind of doing
my job too so I said listen man you
gotta give me twenty four twenty five
more dollars and he's unfunny
[ __ ] but I didn't say no else
cuz there's no else I'm done you know so
he couldn't do it so I did the next best
thing
what are you doing when you're not happy
at a job you start [ __ ] up so I
started getting drunk labor and talking
[ __ ] to him he goes off park whack ass
who up there doing the same [ __ ] you
know just talking [ __ ] about getting his
ear being annoying bro right to the
point where I'm gonna get rid of this
guy i'ma beat his ass mmm-hmm I was just
not happy anymore and well and I don't
care if anybody knows this I'll tell you
right now when we were open whenever we
would do like a theater where the
majority was 90% Mexican I would only do
five minutes
unstaged we're not audiences are white I
would do 35 and although the guy would
do five so I'm doing although I'm doing
all the time man we're in Cleveland
Indiana and I did 35 just Roy that [ __ ]
and you'll have to do an hour
he kills two but then we go to San Jose
you're gonna do five minutes
I said why I can't just do 30 are you
afraid of follow that [ __ ] I said that
bro you've read that 25 bucks hey listen
man I'll do five minutes if you admit to
me are you afraid of follow me and he
just walked away
are you gonna be like Danny just walked
away like a fat lip fat Punk a little
[ __ ] right maybe I'm still mad that's
what the whole 75
yeah I'm just thing if it routed back I
became lame I started getting loaded and
drunk and doing cocaine and being a
burden to everybody and then it got rid
of me mmm ya know no harm done no harm
done and um we don't get along but
that's fine man you know the Beatles
don't talk no more bro you know nobody
nobody was meant to get along you know
you know you grow other people you know
you move on I don't know how long we're
gonna be friends but but you move on you
grow out of people nothing wrong with
that and I don't hate the guy and he was
like very our instrumental in the
beginning of my career and so advising
him you know but you move on you grow
you get better
well we've grown a lot from this
interview man I appreciate you so much
for taking the time to do this is uh
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
[Music]
breath